salut comme donald ouais si les maîtres
noir pour mille et une nuits blanches
bientôt dimanche amis du mouton noir
bonsoir amis du loir moutons soir bon
salut les p'tits gars aux armes et
caetera voilà leur war mutu banc
d'arguin ce bar l'ami caouette
cacahuètes se fait lunettes noires pour
nuits blanches spéciale gainsbourg noir
et c'est un scoop
bonsoir bienvenue aux folies bergères
pour la première de double jeu
le premier jeu en nocturne double je
sais quoi c'est un tiers d'interviews un
tiers de variétés un tiers de jeu un
tiers des rubriques tout ce monde
émission contraint pas je me suis donné
un mal de chien pour la voir j'ai bossé
tout l'hiver thierry ces partis saluent
cette double jeu mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs bonsoir bienvenue aux folies
bergères pour double je
avant tout je voudrais vous remercier
chers téléspectateurs pour votre
fidélité
[ __ ] ça change chers amis chers
ennemis bonsoir c'est l'heure du best-of
de r d hergé le seul jt de la culture
interview critiqué chronique images et
reportages revivez revoyez le meilleur
de la culture sous toutes ses coutures
[Applaudissements]
sur le plateau de tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez le principe tout le
monde en parle
alors tout le monde en parle amis du
samedi soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle vous connaissez le
principe tout le monde en parle alors
tout le monde en parle
amigo 220 thonon iter bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission pas comme les autres vous
connaissez le principe tout le monde en
parle alors tout le monde en parle
bon bon bon sedan bat
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission que ma mère
préfère à l'usl au mont noir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en temps l'émission qui parle
derrière terrienne et tous les autres
aussi bien venu sur le plateau de tout
le monde en parle émission qui appelle
un chat
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui fait encore des bruits
même quand elle est finie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus